Y
FOUR HOURS A DAY. WE REVIEW AND
DEBATE EVERY FINDING COMPARED
TO EXISTING SCIENCE. WEIGHING
THE RISKS AND BENEFITS OF EVERY
INTERVENTION ITS TIMING. IS ANY
AS WELL AS ANY POTENTIAL
IMPACTS THE DELAY. MAY HAVE.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS ILLNESS
THE PRESIDENT HAS EXPERIENCED
TWO EPISODES OF TRANSIENT DROPS
HIS OXYGEN SATURATION. WE
DEBATED THE REASONS FOR THIS
AND WHETHER WE'D EVEN
INTERVENE. THE DETERMINATION
THE TEAM BASED PREDOMINATELY ON
THE TIMELINE FOR THE INITIAL
DIAGNOSIS THAT WE INITIATE
DEXAMETHASONE. I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW GIVES SOME
SPECULATION OVER THE COURSE OF
THE ILLNESS WELL THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS. UPDATE YOU IN THE
COURSE OF HIS HIS OWN ILLNESS.
THURSDAY NIGHT INTO FRIDAY
MORNING WHEN I LEFT THE BEDSIDE
THE PRESIDENT WAS DOING WELL
THE ONLY MILD SYMPTOMS AS
OXYGEN WAS IN THE HIGH NINETIES.
LATE FRIDAY MORNING WHEN I
RETURN TO THE BEDSIDE.
PRESIDENT HAD A HIGH FEVER AS
OXYGEN OXYGEN SATURATION WAS
TRANSLATED BEING. BLOWN 4%
GIVEN THESE TWO DEVELOPMENTS I
WAS CONCERN FOR POSSIBLE RAPID
PROGRESSION OF THE ILLNESS. I
RECOMMENDED THE PRESENT WE TRY
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL OXYGEN SEE
HOW HE RESPONDS. HE WAS FAIRLY
ADAMANT THAT HE DIDN'T NEED IT.
HE'S NOT SHORT OF BREATH. HE
WAS TIRED HAD THE FEVER THAT
WAS ABOUT IT. NOW FOR ABOUT A
MINUTE. ONLY TWO LEADERS.
SATURATION LEVELS ARE BACK OVER
FORTY OVER 95% STATE ON THAT
FOR ABOUT AN HOUR MAYBE IT WAS
OFF AND GONE. LATER THAT DAY BY
THE TIME THE TEAM HERE WITH AT
THE BEDSIDE. PRESIDENT HAD BEEN
UP OUT OF BED MOVING ABOUT THE
RESIDENCE WITH ONLY MILD
SYMPTOMS. DESPITE THIS.
EVERYONE AGREED THE BEST COURSE
OF ACTION WAS TO MOVE TO WALTER
REED FOR MORE THOROUGH
EVALUATION MONITORING. I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE UP DR JULIE
SCUFFS COMPLAINED. THANK YOU DR
CONNELLY- BEFORE I GET A BRIEF
CLINICAL UPDATE ON THE
PRESIDENT'S CONDITION I DO WANT
TO REITERATE MY COMMENTS FROM
YESTERDAY. IN THE- HOW PROUD I
AM TO BE A PART OF THIS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY MULTI
INSTITUTIONAL TEAM OF CLINICAL
PROFESSIONALS BEHIND ME. AND
WHAT AN HONOR IT IS TO CARE FOR
THE PRESIDENT- HERE AT WALTER
REED NATIONAL MILITARY MEDICAL
CENTER. REGARDING ITS CLINICAL
STATUS THE PATIENT CONTINUES TO
IMPROVE- HE HAS REMAINED
WITHOUT FEVER- SINCE FRIDAY
MORNING. HIS VITAL SIGNS ARE
STABLE- FROM A PULMONARY
STANDPOINT HE REMAINS ON ROOM
AIR THIS MORNING- AND IT'S NOT
COMPLAINING OF SHORTNESS OF
BREATH. OR OTHER SIGNIFICANT
RESPIRATORY SYMPTOMS IS
EMULATING- HIMSELF WALKING
AROUND. THE WHITE HOUSE MEDICAL
UNIT. WITHOUT. LIMITATION OR
DISABILITY. OUR CONTINUED
MONITORING OF HIS. CARDIAC
LIVER AND KIDNEY FUNCTION-
DEMONSTRATES CONTINUED NORMAL
FINDINGS OR PROVING FINDINGS OF.
AND I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO-
TO DOCTOR OF ALL THE- FROM
JOHNS HOPKINS TO TALK ABOUT OUR
THERAPEUTICS AND AGAIN ARE
PLANNED FOR THE DAY. THANK YOU
DR JULIANUS ONE OF THE AGAIN TO
REITERATE WHAT AN HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE IT IS TO TAKE CARE OF
THE PRESIDENT BUT TO BE PART OF
SUCH A TALENTED AND MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM HERE. AT
WALTER REED- THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY EVENING COMPLETED A
SECOND DOSE OVER INVESTOR FEAR-
HE'S TOLERATED THAT INFUSION
WHILE WE'VE BEEN MONITORING FOR
ANY POTENTIAL SIDE EFFECTS- AND
HE HAS HAD NONE THAT WE CAN
TELL. HIS LIVER AND KIDNEY
FUNCTION REMAINED NORMAL- AND
WE CONTINUE TO PLAN TO USE A
FIVE DAY COURSE AROUND US HERE.
IN RESPONSE TO TRANSIENT- LOW
OXYGEN LEVELS AS DR. KHAMIS
DISCUSSED WE DID INITIATE
DEXAMETHASONE THERAPY. AND HE
RECEIVED HIS FIRST DOSE OF THAT
YESTERDAY. AND OUR PLAN IS TO
CONTINUE THAT FOR THE TIME
BEING- TODAY HE FEELS WELL HE'S
BEEN UP AROUND ARE PLANNED FOR
TODAY TO HAPPEN TO EAT AND
DRINK- THE UP OUT OF BED AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO BE MOBILE.
AND IF HE CONTINUES TO LOOK AND
FEEL AS WELL AS HE DOES TODAY
OUR HOPE IS THAT WE CAN PLAN
FOR A DISCHARGE AS EARLY AS
TOMORROW. TO THE WHITE HOUSE
WHERE HE CAN CONTINUE HIS
TREATMENT COURSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'LL TURN OVER DR
CONNOLLY FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE. PRESIDENT
ONE OF ME TO SHARE HOW PROUD HE
IS OF THE GROUP. WHAT AN HONOR
IT IS FOR HIM TO BE. EVEN HIS
KERR HERE AT WALTER REED
CENTERS AROUND BY SUCH
INCREDIBLE TALENT ACADEMIC
LEADERS DEPARTMENT CHAIRS
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED
RESEARCHERS AND CLINICIANS.
CLEAN SUPPORT DOCTOR DR BALI
FROM JOHNS HOPKINS- LIKE TO
REITERATE HELP PLEASE WE ALL
ARE. THE PRESIDENT'S RECOVERY.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS. THERE WERE INSTANCES
WHERE HE HAD AND I CAN YOU WALK
US THROUGH THIS ONE AND ALSO I
GOT A QUESTION FOR THE LUNG
SPECIALIST. YEAH YEAH YESTERDAY
OTHERS ANOTHER EPISODE WHERE
DROP DOWN ABOUT NINETY THREE
PERCENT- ISN'T EVER FEEL SHORT
OF BREATH- WE WATCHED IT- AND
IT RETURNED BACK UP- THEY SAID
WE VALUATE ALL OF THESE AND
GIVEN THE TIME LINE WHERE HE IS
IN THE COURSE OF ILLNESS. YOU
KNOW WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
MAXIMIZE EVERYTHING- THAT WE
COULD DO FOR HIM AND- WE
DEBATED WHETHER WE'D EVEN
STARTED. AT THE NEXT EXIT
DEXAMETHASONE AND WE DECIDED
THAT- IN THIS CASE. THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS EARLY ON
COURSE PROBABLY OUTWEIGHED ANY
RISKS AT THIS TIME. THE SECOND
ROUND OF SUPPLEMENTAL OXYGEN
YESTERDAY- I'D HAVE TO I'D HAVE
TO CHECK WITH THE NURSING
STAFF- I DON'T THINK THAT IF
YOU DID IT WAS VERY VERY
LIMITED- BUT- IT'S NOT ON
OXYGEN- AND I THE ONLY OXYGEN
THAT THAT I ORDERED THAT WE
PROVIDED WAS- THAT FRIDAY
MORNING INITIALLY. YESTERDAY
WHAT WAS YESTERDAY AT THE
SECOND INSTANCE SECONDS
INCIDENTS OVER THE COURSE OF
THE DAY YEAH. YESTERDAY MORNING
THAT YOU'RE TRYING. TO CALLING
PRESIDENT LAW OFFICES LEVEL
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION TO
DOCTOR CONLEY 98% WHAT IS THE
R. X. RAYS AND CT SCANS SHOW
ARE THERE SIGNS OF PNEUMONIA
ARE THERE SIGNS OF LONG
INVOLVED. ANY DAMAGE TO THE
LEFT YES WE'RE TRACKING ALL OF
THAT- THERE'S SOME EXPECTED
FINDINGS BUT NOTHING OF A ANY
MAJOR CLINICAL CONCERNED.
THANKS WHITE OXYGEN THE GROUP
DID BELOW THE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RECORDINGS HERE THAT'S RIGHT.
YEAH WE'RE RIGHT HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE OR HEAR ANYTHING
BELOW NINETY JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON HER QUESTION- NO IT WAS
BELOW 94% WAS IT WASN'T DOWN TO
LOW EIGHTIES OR ANYTHING SO
OKAY THAT IS ON THE DOCUMENTED
THE TERRORISTS ARE ON A LOT OF
HOLD US THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
IN GREAT SHAPE TRY BIDDING THAT
SHAPING PEOPLE THREE FOR THE
PREVIOUS TWENTY FOUR HOURS. NOT
EXACTLY A PRESS CONFERENCE
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS TOLD REPORTERS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF IDOLS WERE VERY
CONCERNING OVER THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR HOURS. SIMPLE QUESTION FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE- STATEMENTS.
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT HEALTH
SHOULD BE. SO THE CHIEF I. WORK
SO BY SIDE. AND I THINK HIS
NAME WAS. WHAT HE MEANT. THAT
TWENTY FOUR HOURS AGO. WHEN HE
AND I WERE. CHECKING ON THE
PRESIDENT. THAT THERE WAS THAT
MOMENTARY EPISODE OF THE HIGH
FEVER. AND THAT TEMPORARY JOB-
IN THE SATURATION WHICH-
PROMPTED US. TO ACT- SPEEDILY.
TO MOVE HIM UP HERE.
FORTUNATELY THAT WAS REALLY
VERY VERY TRANSIENT LIMITED
EPISODE. A COUPLE HOURS LATER
HE WAS BACK UP- MILD AGAIN- YOU
KNOW IT'S- NOT LIKE A SPECULATE
WHAT THAT THAT THAT. THE
DEFICIT WAS ABOUT SO EARLY IN
THE COURSE BUT- HE'S DOING WELL
WHAT ARE THE EXPECTED FINDINGS
ON AS LONG AS IN WHY IS THE
PRESIDENT NOT WEARING A MASK IN
THE VIDEOS AND PHOTOS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED. WELL THE PRESIDENT-
WEARS A MASK ANYTIME HE'S HE'S
AROUND US AND WE'RE ALL
WEARING. OUR AND NINETY FIVES-
FULL PP- HE'S HE'S THE PATIENT
IN ONE WEEKEND- WHEN HE'LL MOVE
OUT INTO- DEVELOPING MOVEMENT
OUT ELTON ROUND OTHER PEOPLE.
THAT AREN'T FULL PPE- SURE YOU
HILL- AS LONG AS HE'S- STILL
UNDER MY CARE- WE'LL TALK ABOUT
HIM WEARING HIM. AND HE'S IN A
NEGATIVE PRESSURE ROOM. IN THE
ROOM IS. I NOT GONNA GET A HIS.
OF A HIS K. DONALD. AFTER
CALLING I'M SORRY THE LONG
FUNCTION NEEDS ABOUT THAT IT
WOULD I DON'T JUST SHARE THAT
LIKE EVERY PATIENT WE PERFORMED
LONG IN- SPIROMETRY ON HIM AND-
HE'S MAXING IT OUT WE TOLD
THEM- TO WHAT YOU CAN DO AND
IT'S OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED-
MILLILITERS EACH TIME- HE'S
HE'S DOING GREAT. YEAH KNOWING
REGULARITY. YOU CAN THERE
ANYTHING. AT PRESIDENT HAD BEEN
EIGHT MINUTES OXYGEN. IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION SO. I WAS TRYING
TO REFLECT THE UPBEAT ATTITUDE
THAT THE TEAM PRESIDENT BUSH
COURSE BILL THIS IS HAD- DIDN'T
WANT TO GIVE- ANY ANY
INFORMATION THAT MIGHT- STEER
THE OF THE COURSE OF ILLNESS IN
ANOTHER DIRECTION- AND IN DOING
SO- YOU KNOW CAME OFF. WE'RE
TRYING TO HIDE SOMETHING WAS
INITIALLY TRUE- AND- SO HAVE
HE'S HE IS THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS THAT HE'S DOING
REALLY WELL HE IS HE IS
RESPONDING AND AS A TEAM SAID-
IF EVERYTHING CONTINUES TO GO
WELL WE'RE GONNA START A
DISCHARGE PLAN BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE. THANK FOR. CALLING
AND- YOU CAN YESTERDAY YOU
PLEASE EXPLAIN WHAT YOU FOUND
ON THE LONG. IF YOU WANT. TO
ONE YEAH